-Our next guest
is a Tony-nominated actor
you know from films
such as "Pride & Prejudice"
and the "Pirates
of the Caribbean" franchise,
as well as shows like "The Night
Manager" and "The White Lotus."
He stars in the limited series
"Feud: Capote Vs. The Swans,"
which premieres with two
episodes on January 31st on FX
and streams
the next day on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-I know about you.
I know about your car accident.
Shattered your cheekbones.
How when they rebuilt your face,
you were suddenly
more beautiful than ever.
You became a swan from
an ugly duckling, am I right?
-How do you know
about all that?
-Well, my point is,
the accident was a blessing.
And now there's
something else.
You have a new best friend.
-[ Laughs ]
-Now let's have a cigarette.
-Please welcome to the show
Tom Hollander, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It's so -- Can I tell you
something I love, Tom?
I love when the actor
is unrecognizable from the clip.
That's very exciting to me.
It's a real transformation.
-Yeah. No. Yeah, yeah.
It was.
There were a lot of people
involved in that transformation.
A lot of restaurants.
-A lot of restaurants. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-It was -- I mean,
I would imagine this is --
this is based on a book
about later-era Truman Capote
and his friendship with
socialites in New York City...
-That's right.
-...that he called his swans.
And this is a sort of darker
period of Truman Capote's life.
Did you know about
this era of Truman Capote?
-I knew that he was
a terrible drunk
and that Studio 54 and --
but I also knew him as a writer.
I had read his stuff
when I was young.
I didn't know how dark it went.
And I didn't know about
his close relationship
with these fancy ladies
and how they -- how he
destroyed himself with them.
He was kind of addicted
to fancy people
in the same way
that he was addicted to booze.
He felt these things
could make him whole and --
but he also kind of despised it
and despised himself.
So he kind of blew it up
and ended up --
It's a dark tale.
Yeah.
-No, I should say
it's a dark tale,
but it is still --
it is a fun char--
I mean, "character"
is the wrong word,
but he's a fun person
to play, right?
I mean, it just might seem
like the juiciest role.
Yeah, he's one of these people
that leaves --
when they die,
they leave endless opportunities
for actors to come along.
I'm giving my Truman Capote now.
Yeah, he was
a larger-than-life character,
and he's an icon
of American literature
and society.
And so I was very, very glad
and lucky
to be offered the part,
and I loved every second of it.
-He obviously has
a very distinctive voice,
speaking style.
How do you approach it
where it's not --
you're embodying the man
without doing what seems like
or looks like an impression?
-Well, you have to do
a little bit of an impression.
And then you have to
allow yourself to go,
"Well, I'm not exactly
like Truman Capote.
I don't look like
Truman Capote,"
as you can see from the clip,
but you're giving a performance
where anyone watching it
would go,
"Well, that can only be
Truman Capote."
It's not,
"That's Truman Capote."
It's, "That's Truman Capote."
So I was doing that,
and Robbie Baitz,
who's the genius writer
who wrote it, said,
"You don't have to be
Truman Capote.
We're playing
Truman Capote the myth."
And it's eight-episode
extravaganza,
which is a sort of fantasia,
some of it.
It keeps going 'round
and 'round in time.
You see the same events
presented in different ways.
Each episode is wildly different
tonally from the next episode.
They really threw
the kitchen sink at it.
Is that the expression?
-Yeah.
-Nailed it.
-Some kitchen sinks
and some more glamorous things
than kitchen sinks.
Yeah, it was amazing.
-I know you've worked
in New York on Broadway.
You've been here before, but you
got to shoot this in New York
and also obviously on sets that
were New York from a bygone era.
Did you like those styles,
that fashion, the look of it?
-Yes, the whole thing
was like a sort of --
'Cause I feel, you know, I'm a
tourist when I come to America.
And this was like
historical tourism.
I was seeing this world
of the Upper East Side
and these fancy houses
and the Hamptons
and the way they lived.
And the sets are astonishing.
The costumes by Lou Eyrich
are astonishing.
There was no expense spared,
apparently, on this.
And it was --
it was an education.
And I was learning
about him, as well,
and the way people
felt about him
and the whole generation
of people
who grew up watching him
on television
being extraordinary
and being extreme on TV
and coming onto shows
like this
but, you know, having been up
for two days and being drunk
and being wild and being bitchy.
And so obviously I could watch
all of that to research it
and Philip Seymour Hoffman,
the great
Philip Seymour Hoffman,
who, you know,
unfortunately, got an Oscar
for playing the role,
so that was intimidating.
But, I mean,
not that he wasn't brilliant,
obviously, but, you know,
"Oh, he got an Oscar."
[ Laughter ]
But luckily this is
a very different story from --
It's a different Truman Capote.
-I'm surprised to hear
the first time
you have played an American.
-It is. Yeah.
-'Cause most British people,
I hope you know,
play them all the time.
-They only play Americans.
-They're constantly
taking our jobs.
I don't want to get
on my soapbox.
-I know, but they do it
for less.
That's why.
It's just a basic --
They're just
undercutting everyone, yeah.
No, I always wanted
to play an American, yeah.
I wanted -- been desperate
to play an American.
And, yeah, here I was doing it,
and I loved it.
I grew up watching
the war movies
where the Americans
had much better uniforms.
They just had cooler hats.
They had cooler cars.
They were just --
And I still think Americans
are quite cool.
So I --
-Give us time.
-I know that's wrong.
I know.
I know I'm a fool, but I do.
America's a wonderful,
wonderful country.
So I liked pretending
to be part of it for a minute.
-Yeah, it is funny
when your first American role
is Truman Capote,
because I do feel like
he's weirdly like --
Even though he only
could be American,
it's not like he is
quintessentially American.
-No, I suppose not.
Perhaps that's -- Perhaps --
Would you like
to expand on that?
-I guess, like --
Like, what I would
like you to --
I would also like to see you as,
like, a flat Midwestern farmer
in something.
-Yes, yes.
-You know what I mean?
That's the American I want
to see Tom Hollander play.
-Yeah. Or -- Yeah.
Or a kind of docker somewhere
or a taxi driver.
-Yeah. Do you want to do
taxi driver real quick?
-Robert De Niro
in "Taxi Driver"?
-No, just like any --
just do your best American --
-[ American accent ] No, this
guy. I'd like to play this guy.
-Yeah, we all want that.
-I want to do this.
-We all want that.
-I want to do that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were so wonderful
in "White Lotus,"
second season of "White Lotus."
I'm sure you hear it
al the time, deservedly so.
-[ Normal voice] Thank you.
-And the line,
"These gays are trying
to murder me," even --
Jennifer Coolidge even said it
in her acceptance speech
at the Emmys.
I feel like it's going to be
part of -- I don't know.
It's going to be a quote
for all time.
-Yes.
-Do people ever yell it at you?
-Not at me, no, but, I mean,
they obviously
yell it at her a lot,
but I'm -- they --
No, they're too scared.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-There's a couple of lines
that people come up with,
that people quote.
I had a line
about potatoes in.
Something about "these excellent
boiled potatoes" in one thing.
-[ Cheers ]
-Yeah. See, someone --
I don't even remember saying it.
And a line about "difficult
difficult lemon difficult."
Does anyone remember
that one from "In the Loop"?
That was it. Yeah.
-I think "In the Loop was maybe
the first time I saw you.
That was a fantastic film.
-That was very well written.
Yeah, yeah.
-I have to ask you.
I feel like it's almost
the elephant in the room.
There's an actor
named Tom Holland.
-Oh, yeah.
-Does that ever -- Do people
ever make that error?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. It's been very difficult.
'Cause, you know,
I was here first.
-Yeah.
-But he's enormously famous,
so I --
Obviously, I don't actually
get mistaken for him,
but in non-visual contexts, I am
mistaken for him all the time.
So, like, talking to utility
companies, they just,
"And what's your name?"
And they go, "Tom Holland?"
'Cause they've heard
Tom Holland, Tom Holland.
You go,
"No, it's Tom Hollan-der."
Or I'm introduced to somebody
very, very excited,
then confused,
then disappointed children
who they go, "My children
are so excited to meet you."
And I go, "Are they, though?"
And then, "Okay, well..."
"Oh, no, they really are."
"Okay, I don't think they are,
but bring them out."
And they come out and they go,
"Where is he? Where is he?"
And they go, "No, no."
[ Laughter ]
And people in the accounts
department of my agency
got confused,
and we were with
the same agency briefly.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
And it was a terrible moment.
I went to see my friend who was
doing theater in England and --
for £300 a week, you know,
but doing great work, Chekhov,
and I sat smugly
in the audience,
having just done a BBC show
for 30 grand or something,
which was, you know,
going to get me
through the next year or so.
And I was thinking,
"Well, this is marvelous.
I'm very prosperous,
but my good friend Peter
is doing this great play,
and I'm going to go afterwards
and see him
and slightly patronize him
and say how wonderful it was."
And then the interval came
and I thought
I'd check my e-mails,
and I got an e-mail
from the agency saying,
"Payment advice,
your first box-office bonus
for 'The Avengers.'"
And, um...
[ Laughter ]
And I thought...
..."I don't think
I'm in 'The Avengers.'"
And it was an astonishing
amount of money.
And it was not his salary.
It was his first
box-office bonus,
not the whole box office,
the first one.
And it was more money
than I've ever --
It was a seven-figure sum.
-Yeah, they had to send it
in two e-mails.
-He was 20 or something.
So my feeling of smugness
that you remember I had
in the first half
disappeared very quickly.
But that's showbiz.
It's up, it's down,
it's hero, it's zero.
-You're always one e-mail away
from having your whole life
turned upside down.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations on the show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
What a delight.
What a delight to talk to you.
-Thank you.
-Tom Hollander, everyone.
FX's "Feud:
Capote Vs. The Swans"
premieres on Wednesday,
January 31st,
and streams the next day
on Hulu.